sometimes there are nights where I think
I have a tough gig mostly I think this
is a really sweet gig but comedy can be
tough I think you have a very difficult
job because you were dealing with sports
fans and as you know they are insane and
they're constantly constantly on the
lookout for someone like you
play-by-play write it to say see me
coming they see you coming and they're
waiting and they can dissect anything
you say and they can take exception to
it and you can people get really mad at
you no they do you know and I get it
because when the games count the most I
show up but all year long especially in
baseball Cub fans are listening to the
cub announcers Indian fans are listening
to the Indians announcers and the Giants
and the Dodgers and they want to hear
their guys and then I show up and I'm
not rooting for either side writer you
are the National announced each side
thinks I'm somehow rooting against their
team yes so it sucks yes it sucks to the
degree some people there is a shot I
think you even put this up yourself but
this we did you retweeted this look at
this shot right here if we broadcast the
old buck jump by the Zodiac killer yeah
now that's it Wrigley that's outside
really Joe Buck is the Zodiac killer I
have an alibi yeah no I looked into it
it's shaky I was gonna eight-year-old
serial killer in the late 70s welcoming
on this show on show on that sign is
exactly what the zodiac wouldn't fair
enough
you know the thing is that you can't
make anybody happy now that's a Cubs fan
that was you said that was angry with
you but we're a Cleveland fans in this
last series who believed they were
listening and they found Joe Buck is
rooting for the Cubs now in fairness
there are a lot of people that were
rooting for the Cubs because it was a
slightly greater longshot I think you
know and so it hadn't happened for a
hundred and eight years right and no I I
think if we're guilty of rooting for
anything it's long series and good games
in the series I I really honestly don't
care who wins in the end but when you
get a series like we got and it's
Cleveland that hasn't won in forever and
the Cubs who haven't won since before
the Titanic went
right you know there's a lot on the line
and so there's there's a lot of emotion
involved from the from the fans a an
Indians fan posted on the internet these
pictures of you in compromising pictures
with Kyle schwarber of the clubs of the
Cubs and look at this they showed there
we are there you are that I will never
forget that movie 3d think that's the
Titanic we were actually in the bar
business this we're watching the
notebook naturally no very nice and now
so there's a real bride I mean I make a
hot bride I'm not gonna lie to you that
wasn't photoshopped no I was actually
couch warmer and me now I was you
actually sounded surprised we were all
watching Indies a huge Cubs fan I'm just
a baseball fan Red Sox fan but when the
Cubs won everybody was blown away but it
was kind of fun to hear in a
professionals voice and your voice you
genuinely seemed stunned I you know yeah
I remember a call my dad broadcast for
the Cardinals for 50 years and I
remember always being in love with the
call he had of a no-hitter that Bob
Gibson through because in the last pitch
and the last out I can hear his voice
crack with emotion and he was an easy
cry and I think he thought this is a
beautiful thing to see a no-hitter and
when they won I'm screaming and yelling
that the Cubs have finally won the World
Series it finally won it all my voice
kind of cracked and I was like my god
they won all right take it easy
that's what I thought that's not what
you said I loved it you didn't say that
on Fox yeah I'm here to turn or you're
ready to go yeah oh good I'm in this
seedy neighborhood I could talk however
at watch Jeff Ross is already on the
phone can he say he was trying to get a
restaurant reservation oh you know they
have a little while longer to weigh him
yeah you're almost done up he's on he's
like he likes to call the Olive Garden
early now no no salads no limit on but I
believe I can't get in
you